i call it the best kept secret in
history are essentially two questions
number one did the ancient greeks use
drugs to find god and number two do the
earliest christians
inherit part of that tradition if the
answer to both of those questions
is yes then it means that western
civilization as we know it was somewhat
founded on
a visionary experience and christianity
the world's biggest religion today
with two and a half billion people might
be tapping into those same
psychedelic waters
you're a qualified lawyer why are you
talking about the psychedelic origins of
western civilization
that's a great question i feel like i'm
i'm still a barrister still bad do you
is that what you call it barristering uh
lawyering look being a being a barrister
being a barristering yeah if anyone can
tell us if the verb is too barrister
[Laughter]
so i still do that believe it or not i'm
i'm still in good standing in new york
state in washington dc
for the moment and uh i don't know i
don't know i just i started reading
about psychedelics and i couldn't stop
but weren't tempted to try them you
actually sorry decided not to try them
you remained uh psychedelically
uninitiated
throughout the writing of your book my
virginity
was and remains intact
is that going to change at any point
soon soon
in the coming years i'm not sure exactly
when but
as it becomes legal and as the
facilities
come online where you can have an
experience that is
uh you know responsible and
scientifically rigorous and also
for me authentically sacred and
historical i think that'll be my moment
it's going to be so fascinating to see
what happens to you
having spent over a decade thinking
reflecting considering and then
also going into wondering what other
people's experiences are like the
the meta experience what did they think
what did they feel
man whatever it is that you end up going
through is
you're gonna be shot into another
universe
i can't wait i'm always part of me is
always thinking the great irony of all
this
would be if absolutely nothing happened
all this time all this time
i was wrong [ __ ] what a waste it was
all a big troll
is there a movie coming out is there a
movie coming out about the book
um we we hope so um at least a
documentary series
so we're busy pitching that to different
networks and streamers uh here in the us
but obviously it'll have a global
audience
dude that's so cool
yeah man we have that that's that's been
a you know a
big part of my my job the past few weeks
and months
but negotiating what sort of a series it
should be
who should play you can we get tom hanks
all that sort of stuff
uh all of the above and where do you go
and how do you get there and why are you
doing it and is this you know
is this one episode is this a thousand
episodes and how do we pair
the mystery and suspense with the
rigorous academic scholarship and you
know make it make it a feast for the
eyes and for the ears
it's got to be a killer soundtrack right
nice yeah so it's going to be
barristering writing producing
the triple threat that's the that's the
big triple threat
that's my new business card chris i love
it i love it if you need an agent speak
to me so right later honestly what
what's the story arc
of history that you're following here
right so it's um you know i call it the
best kept secret in history which
which is not my words these are the
words of houston smith
uh who if you've never heard of him he's
one of the most influential scholars of
the 20th century
and what he was referring to are
essentially two questions number one did
the ancient greeks use drugs to find god
and number two did the earliest
christians inherit part of that
tradition
if the answer to both of those questions
is yes then it means that
you know like western civilization as we
know it was somewhat founded on
a visionary experience and christianity
the world's biggest religion today
with two and a half billion people might
be tapping into those same
psychedelic waters so these are big
questions obviously very controversial
and there's lots of great literature out
there and artifacts you can go hunt down
but what i tried to do over the past 12
years
is sniff out the hard scientific data to
really make you know heads or tails of
this for the first time
why does it matter or why is there a
distinction between it happening just
for the greeks and it happening for
also the foundation of christianity
so the first chapter of my book is
called identity crisis
and it talks a lot about this i mean at
some point or for a long time
there was no separation between church
and state and i feel like in
the west we're still grappling at least
in the united states we're still growing
well in the uk as well we're still
grappling
with this sense of the sacred and the
profane i mean so the old narrative is
that the ancient greeks
birthed uh political life as we know it
and gave us the arts and sciences and
the concept of a university
and you know we took their theaters and
made it into hollywood
and we took their olympic games and we
made it into the sports industry
and all this stuff that they gave us you
know they were able to do all this but
when it came to the meaning of life
you know they got it all wrong it's the
prevailing narrative and here comes
jesus in christianity
and the christianized roman empire and
they're the ones who go off and
evangelize
and they're the ones who colonized the
americas for example and africa and asia
it was this um it was this
evangelization movement you know
and we live in 2021 on no domini the
year of our lord i mean so
there's all these identity crises that i
think we're still grappling with like
sometimes we're greek and rational and
sometimes we're very christian
and and irrational faith-based um
and what which is it and how do we heal
that divide um so if you can answer both
of those questions and weirdly if
psychedelics
is the thing that unites the ancient
greeks and the christians
when you know we're hard of trying to
figure out anything that unites them
uh what a powerful story absolutely so
where do we begin what's the
what even suggests why psychedelics
so i mean i i spent years after asking
myself the same question it starts
for me it started in 1955. uh i wasn't
there
uh but in the this guy gordon wassen uh
who
uh like me was working on wall street he
was working
at j.p morgan this former banker turned
ethnomycologist he became obsessed with
mushrooms
and went all around the world hunting
them we think he's the first to really
document this ceremony
in the mass texts of mexico psilocybin
containing mushrooms under the
tutelage of maria sabina he takes the
mushrooms in a very ritual setting
and he has a crazy you know visionary
experience but what's weird about gordon
is that instead of saying just oh wow
was it wasn't that some crazy geometry
of
crazy visuals or what the hell was that
this guy because he's well read
and lettered you know he says i think
that i've tapped into the platonic
archetypes
he says that these divine mushrooms must
have been what was behind the ancient
mysteries
because what happened to me was so real
so vivid and so clear
that i think i've tapped into the
realest version of reality and if i just
did that here in 1955
maybe our ancient ancestors 2500 years
ago were doing the same thing because
psychedelics are freaking they're a mind
buster
uh and so when someone like that is
doing psychedelics and thinking about
the classics
and history um without doing them i was
relying on his testimony
to kind of ferret out the same details i
was reading these studies
coming out of hopkins very similar kind
of testimony one and only dose of
psilocybin
crazy visuals crazy mystical insights
and the first thing i think of is gordon
watson
and his theory that maybe the greeks
were doing this and i slashed to this
book from 1978
where they were uh spouting this
controversial theory that
psychedelics are the roots of western
civilization and off i go
why like that that's a
a wonderful postulated theory from some
guy that once did mushrooms but that
doesn't necessarily justify doing 12
years of a book on it
that's a good that's a good point my
wife mentioned something similar at some
point
um so where's the i mean that's my point
so where's the data so
in 1978 what they had was really
interesting literary references
around what was happening at ellucis and
so for those who don't know ellucis
is like the spiritual capital of the
ancient world it survives for about two
thousand years
that is to say as long as christianity
over the past two thousand it called
to everybody from plato in classical
athens to marcus aurelius and the roman
empire centuries later
and they all talk about this vision they
all talk about this life
transforming event like if you went to a
lucius um
you confronted death and became an
immortal only people who'd gone there
and had this experience walked away from
it
guaranteed of an afterlife that's where
you went to get your afterlife
and so it's this really central pivotal
moment
in greek history in the history of
western civilization uh
and there's some testimony from plato
and others that they saw this thing
and there's old poetry like the hindu
demeter
from a couple centuries before that
which talks about this magic potion
and it lists out the ingredients of this
potion called the cookie on
um and what we're told in the ancient
literature and the ancient sources that
survived and not much survived because
this was all secret but what we're left
with is the idea of this magical beer
that propelled this vision and it was
water mint and barley
which again is not something to stake 12
years of your life on but
according to gordon watson and albert
hoffmann who discovers lsd in 1938
they were kind of reading between the
lines and they said it's not water
uh you know barley and mint it's water
ergatized barley
and mint so barley they've been infected
by ergot
ergot is where we get lsd and it's a
really really elegant theory because
ergot is totally natural
it pops up on all the cereal crops and
uh it's interesting to think that that
may have been there
2500 years ago or a lot longer by the
way
which i explore in the book but again no
hard scientific data to support that
what would be the reason for someone an
intellectual like plato
or an emperor like marcus aurelius what
would be the reason for them to go to
this
bizarre place and have some odd ritual
and change their state i thought that
they would be much more
down-to-earth grounded humans
i think that's the thing that brought
them down to earth uh so
you know marcus aurelius a classic
textbook stoic
um he didn't just go to ellucis and
again this place survives from the
ancient greek times to the ancient roman
times
and marcus israelis is the perfect
example of why because someone like him
we think he's one of the only laypeople
to go inside the holy of holies
in this sanctuary this temple at a
losses it was almost destroyed in the
second century a.d and he rebuilds it
to roman standards he wanted to keep
this thing alive this thing that
had spoken to his ancestors and all of
our ancestors
in the west going back to ancient greek
times there was something very
very powerful and very special about
this place
that's difficult to to capture in words
but i i think that you know at the
center of greek existence was this idea
that
you can't think your way into
enlightenment
or you can't read your way into
enlightenment if you read through plato
what he says
about philosophy he says true philosophy
is nothing else but the practice of
dying and being dead
and so at the concept that these greeks
were obsessed obsessed with
investigating death
the same way they would investigate the
other phenomena in the natural world i
mean to them
elusive was more of a science than a
religion you went there to test the god
hypothesis
to have this vision for yourself and
peer back the veil
on reality and see what's there what is
the day before you die
quote can you say that in the original
language for us
right so that comes to us in greek and
it's inscribed on a plaque at st
paul's monastery mount athos in greece
one of the holiest sites in orthodox
christianity
but i think it does tap back because of
this greek lineage into ancient times
and it goes um
if you die before you die you won't die
when you die
um and and i think this is the kind of
thing that was practiced at a losses
this kind of near-death experience this
pre-death
experience that many walked away from
saying was one of the most meaningful
events of their lives
and that ties in with what we're seeing
at johns hopkins at the moment right
that
it's one of the top five most meaningful
spiritual experiences that they've had
it's also being used as a tool to help
avoid or
deal with death anxiety for people who
are perhaps terminally
ill as well right and that i mean
i didn't answer your question but that
that's why i went down the rabbit hole
so there's lots of ancient
uh literature testimony data for what
it's worth but
you know in 2007 and eight i was reading
those studies
and since then this this crazy statistic
has remained
stable um if you talk to roland
griffiths at johns hopkins today for
example he'll say that 75
of those volunteers over the past
roughly 20 years 75
3 and 4 will call their one and only
dose
among the most meaningful experiences of
their lives if not the most meaningful
experience and so
not having done psychedelics i can still
look at that kind of stat
and think there's probably something
there can you describe
based on what you know what the research
has suggested what
ellucis would look like let's say that
we're a bird's-eye view or in a drone
and we can go around what would be
happening who would be there where
is it what's what's going on yeah well
it's a pretty fun place or i think um
you know it attracted all kinds of
different people
um i think it was probably less burning
man and more
fight club um you know psychedelic
sight club yeah i think it was a
psychedelic fight club
of the ancient world um there was
definitely a party atmosphere
or or a raucous nature to it i mean so
it's a nine-day
night extravaganza it starts in athens
and you make
you do this processional march you make
a ritual
pilgrimage 13 miles from athens all the
way to ellucis
and along the way there's all kinds of
roddy
body behavior and women lifting skirts
and telling dirty jokes and all kinds of
fun stuff and then you get there
um and it's serious as a heart attack uh
you know you um
you experience eventually the
culmination of these nine days and
nights is a night inside the temple this
all night this panuchia
this all-night affair in this torch-lit
sanctuary that was dedicated to the
goddess demeter
and along with you we think um the the
the temple could accommodate about 3
000 people uh there were kind of like
stairs that line the perimeter
of this sanctuary um at some point a
gong is struck
a light emits from the center of the
temple
um this is after a magic potion's been
passed around
and here a pair appears persephone the
goddess of the underworld
and sometimes she's described as holding
a baby
the baby dionysus or the baby yahus
and it's this idea that from death
springs life
um and you know it's it's interpreted
for a long time is just this very
visceral initiation into
uh the cycles of fertility and the
seasonal cycles but there was something
very personal happening to these
people so they didn't just like see a
stage act
it wasn't just stage craft there may
have been some of that going on but
again all the testimony what little
survived
tells us there was something deeply
personal about whatever they witnessed
there
hence the theory that part of what they
were witnessing was in the mind's eye
you know with behind behind closed eyes
for example something
perhaps psychedelic it seems
juxtaposed to have something that's
incredibly sacred where
only one layperson got to go marcus
aurelius
and yet there's this raucous nature on
the way there what's going on
it's it's a great question i think you
know um
so there's also a mardi gras element
right uh there's mardi gras and fight
club and burning it's
it's a mix of all this it's definitely a
public festival at some point right
um and i think
it's breaking down boundaries it's
breaking down physical boundaries and
mental boundaries and it's kind of it's
it's like it's intentional mind benders
you know
um you know making just just horrible
jokes at you to kind of
break down your ego before you even get
there and on your first visit you're not
you're not deemed eligible enough to see
that magical vision so you have to visit
twice
which is why this whole initiation
sequence lasts at least a year and a
half
so you don't drink you don't drink on
the first time
no you become a moose days that that was
the title you got on your first visit
you become a mustache which is a mystic
it's only on your second visit that you
became an apoptese which in greek is
kind of like
um you know somebody who sees it all and
so
it was a long long process to get there
um and you know part of it is
intellectual instruction and part of it
is a really rigorous you know physical
exhausting march where you show up
um thirsty and hungry and just kind of
beaten down
and i think those are the conditions
after all that priming or maybe just the
right medicine
would put you into the state of mind to
actually experience some kind of death
and rebirth
who would be invited so technically
anybody could go under two conditions
you had to speak some ancient greek
and you can't have committed murder so
if you're not a murderer
and you know some greek you're in okay
so i run i run nightclubs in the uk
and it would be interesting if my door
policy was based on that
excuse me mate do you speak do you speak
ancient greek and have you committed a
murder
it's like well i can i can whack some
greek out to you but i'm afraid
on the second character i'm gonna have
to go somewhere else
um yeah it might be the only nightclub
where i'd be welcome
perhaps perhaps indeed what are the what
are the mysteries
then you talk about it throughout the
book what are the mysteries
right so ellucis is one example of the
mysteries that existed in the ancient
world i talk about the mysteries of
dionysus
in ancient greece there are lots of
other mysteries that samuthrace the
mysteries
the egyptian mysteries of isis and
osiris the
mysteries of magda mater and different
cults from the near east i mean
if you had to break it all down and say
something very simple i would i would
say that these are
ceremonial experiences of death and
rebirth
so something is happening where you're
shedding your identity
and you're losing that identity in some
kind of ego dissolving event
and you're being reborn reawakened into
a new identity and that identity
is something that is in accord with the
natural world and in accord with the
cosmos
um so clearly there's an experience
happening there
that that's why i always say an
experience of death and rebirth not not
just like
um you know crazy theory or something
you were listening to
uh but but a real visceral experience
why
was all of this if it's such a
transformative experience
three thousand people going is it annual
was every year
it was uh we think around the fall
equinox once a year
every year and it was lasting for quite
a long time and there's multiple
different
of these mysteries if that's the case
why is it seemingly kept hidden then
like sacred religion is written
and repeated everywhere why is this
sacred ritual not
i've been asking myself the same
question for many years i mean so i'll
tell you
i'm not i've been asked this question
before but i'm going to answer it
differently this time um
i'm going to say this i i i think that
because the way i describe it the
ceremonial death and rebirth
my personal belief is that i i think
there is something to do with the
anticipation
and i think that if you know what's
about to happen to you it takes away
some of the magic
and and i think part of the reason this
was kept secret is because you're not
supposed to know what's happening to you
so imagine
if you will like initiation into a
secret society
right and you know you come into the
sacred chamber
and you see a pool filled with
alligators hungry alligators
and you know your mates tell you you
gotta hop into that pool and get out the
other side and then you're one of us
and you say holy [ __ ] why would why
would i do that you know it's a it's a
it's a death sentence and so you hop in
you get through the whole thing and it's
the most terrifying experience of your
life and out you come reborn
now if you'd been told beforehand that
those alligators were perfectly well fed
and didn't want anything to do with you
it would kind of take away from the
experience
and so i think ellucis is something
similar there was this priming
going on and this anticipation that was
being built up
and this mythology that was transmitted
from generation to generation
if you know exactly what's going to
happen if you know you're going to drink
this potion and it's not going to kill
you
but it will you know mess with your
senses for a while if you're told
you know every detail of that i don't i
don't think it's as special
why in that case i i understand why it
might have been kept
quiet from the people who were going but
in terms of noting things down in
history if you've got
over a couple of hundred years several
thousand
tens of thousands of people perhaps
attending this you would have thought
that it would have been
easier to find the most transformative
experience of
30 000 people's lives why are you
scrabbling for little
scraps of paper and having to go to the
vatican and
run off to greece and ask to do testing
on the inside of pots and stuff like
that
surely it would be written everywhere
well i mean
i'd ask the same question about jesus i
want to know what jesus
was all about and this religion of two
and a half billion people
and the guy never wrote a goddamn word
down and so we're left
with these four somewhat contradictory
gospels that are written a generation
after
after his death uh we're left with the
epistles of saint paul who never
met the guy in the flesh you know he
receives all his information
and these visionary experiences and yet
it's the world's biggest religion man
that's two and a half billion people and
we don't have a word from this guy i
mean how is that possible
very very good point so what happened
like you've got this amazing
transformative
ceremony why is it still not happening
today
so there's a lot of different answers to
that um part of the answer i talked
about this in the book i mean part of
the answer is the christianized roman
empire the the christian emperors
weren't too happy
with lucius and the other pagan
traditions stalking around
messing up the show and so by the end of
the fourth century a.d
um a number of decrees are issued in the
second half of that century trying to do
away with this stuff
they try to do away with nocturnal
ceremonies which would include a lucius
and then it comes back
um and you know a lot of the old
libraries and statuary
um kind of disappear not exclusively at
the hands of the christianized roman
empire
but there's this generational loss of
knowledge and to your point if nothing's
written down
there's no doctrine there's no dogma
there's no records for this stuff
if anything's going to go up in smoke
pretty quickly it's something like these
mysteries
have you got any idea of what the last
time it happened
would be said it went away came back
more or less i mean so in the last
decade of the 4th century a.d
392 more or less is the last time i
think we see this celebrated in a ritual
way
and how's the banning of these rituals
described like what went on was it
burning down the
temple and
see at some point this is why i say you
can't exclusively blame the christians i
mean at some point the barbarians get
their hands on a losses and the big
question is you know how do they just
march in and take this place
down well they did it once in the second
century it happens again at the end of
the fourth century but
you know part of me thinks that the
christian emperor is kind of open the
gates
and just uh let the writers stampede um
so why does this matter like what what
are the implications
if it's true the broader implications
other than
plato and marcus aurelius and a bunch of
other famous people that we know about
had a great time
because what if this is the real
religion of the ancient greeks and and
what if this identity crisis that we
have is a false one
you know what if the people who created
the foundations for our life today
were the same people who were very
obsessed with finding out a meaning for
life i mean
what if it in addition to our faith
traditions in addition to the bible the
new testament what if in addition to all
that
these ancient philosophers and mystics
had ideas that weren't that distinct
from christian mystics and some of these
heretical sex like the gnostics
or some of the very mainstream followers
of jesus i mean the big question i ask
in the book is
you know is the ancient greek of the
pagan world
and their rights and practices at all
related to the ancient greek of the new
testament
and their rights and practices and you
know again it's the
greek is the sacred language of
christianity and so by looking into
these mysteries
um what i'm really studying is what's
called the pagan continuity hypothesis
was there something about plato and the
rest of them and his philosophy and
these
rights at ellucis is there some of that
that actually made its way into
christianity
into the earliest christian communities
that we know for
300 years were practicing secret illegal
mystery traditions inside private homes
and graveyards i mean there's a lot of
crossover
it seems to me looking back at
what i know about greek philosophy and
what i understand about christianity
that they do seem like two pieces of
opposite puzzles or of the same puzzle
perhaps
that you had this incredibly grounded
very uh virtuous not
to woowoo there was limited at least in
my experience to do with the greeks
they had their gods but it wasn't a as
sort of a personal transcendence
uh type of philosophy with regards to
that whereas
with christianity almost everything was
about the theology it was about the
paying tribute to the higher power and a
lot less to do with the personal
sovereignty that seems to be
based around the greeks and it it does
seem odd
that you could go from a society that
we're now
in 2020 that ryan holiday is making a
living off
in 2020 you could go from such a
pragmatic
society and philosophy into one
that i think even to christians now
they're not superbly proud of a lot of
the things that went on around that time
there was
it was very militant the way that
christianity kind of came aboard with
conversions and crusades and things like
that
it really does feel like there is a
missing piece there
and that's what i'm looking for and and
part of the hard you know
the hard investigation is that when you
go looking for answers you find
this sacred territory split into two
departments
uh so you know in most universities most
institutions
theology is is very different from the
classics
so if you're interested in what all the
pagans were up to you're studying
classics you're studying the ancient
greek works of plato
and others if you're into the jesus
stuff same language by the way
um you're suddenly in the theology
department or divinity studies
and there's a quote i have in the book
from an old scholar from like the early
20th century
who says that you know the literature
and civilization of a very extensive
part of world history
is very much neglected by the very ones
best able to investigate it which is the
classicist i mean these are the people
who study uh you know all the that
powerful
syntax and grammar and and gorgeous
language of the ancient greek and when
you ask a classicist to read the new
testament
they read it a little bit differently
which is why i got obsessed with this
theory from 1978.
um it wasn't just gordon watson and
albert hoffman who i mentioned it was
carl ruck
this harvard yale trained classicist who
reads the new testament very differently
from the way your average priest might
read it and he reads it with the lens of
a pagan
and with the lens of someone who was
initiated into these mystery schools
um and i say i said linda pagan which is
not fair he's a good catholic boy
just like me just like me
what outside of the rhetoric and what
was written down
and the presence of ergot in the
uh barley or in the wheat um what other
convincing
evidence have you found
um i i'm looking at everything right so
part of me is looking for the hard
scientific data is is there
actual which we haven't talked about yet
but is there any you know
archaeobotanical data for one of these
spiked beers these ergatized beers or
one of these spiked wines out there i
mean that that's a whole separate
question but like
what's in the literature um you know
just from the literary perspective and
this is what classicists do is they read
the old texts and find out what's there
i mean
i didn't spend a lot of time reading
dice scories when i was learning latin
and greek
but afterwards i started reading his
materia medica and he writes this
dioscoretes is the father of drugs
and he writes this massive treatise in
ancient greek in the first century a.d
the same time the gospels are being
written and in his
magnum opus he has all these formulas
these recipes for spiking wine
with all kinds of funky herbs and plants
and different things and he says even at
one
point that one of these plants will
cause not
unpleasant visions fantasias
so he's talking about psychedelics at
the same time
that matthew mark and luke are writing
their gospels and later john and it
makes you wonder you know if the greeks
knew about all this stuff if they knew
about pharmacology
what are the odds that some of that
pharmacology would make its way
into the same ancient greek speaking
communities who had inherited all this
stuff from their ancestors
um one place you would look at is
corinth for example you know paul's
letter to the corinthians
you hear it at every wedding you go to
corinth today is 45 minutes to the west
of ellucis
this ancient spiritual capital now what
are the odds that an early corinthian
who heard about this uh this son of god
born of a virgin
with this new magical gift of immortal
wine this magic potion
what are the odds that either they
themselves or someone they knew was not
initiated had a losses where this magic
potion
had been splashing around for for
centuries and centuries
and so to me the gospels are playing off
of this pagan continuity
what research has been done into the
archaeobotany
or the archaeochemistry of it
so that that's the fun part that's the
fun part um the short answer is not a
hell of a lot
so i had to i had to try and find out
the the scholars were working on this
stuff and i eventually came across
andrew coe who's at mit
uh i mean i i would say the world's
leading archaeochemist
he's responsible amongst other things
for unearthing the world's oldest wine
cellar
in galilee the same gallery where jesus
is born except
it dates it it dates well before jesus
to about 1700 bc from the canaanite
period
and it's wine that again through gas
chromatography mass spectrometry
uh their finding is spiked with all
kinds of funky stuff like
honey storage turbine cypress cedar etc
etc now
you know you might say oh it's just
interesting you know aromatic flavor
profile enhancing type stuff and that's
certainly true
but the big question i'm always asking
andrew is were there other psychoactive
additives psychotropic additives and
theoretically his answer has always been
yes
uh why not let's go find the data so you
know based off some leads from him
i was pouring into these archaeo botany
journals and
eventually came across um a couple
different things
so one hit for ancient beer one hit for
ancient wine
both discovered in the 1990s and largely
ignored by the academic community and as
best as i can tell like never report it
to the public uh just archaeologists
doing what they do finding amazing
things and there it sits in
a journal but in spain from the second
century bc
uh i came across this study of an
ancient greek sanctuary there were
greeks in spain just like there were
greeks in
greece and italy and from the second
century bc they found this tiny chalice
about a couple inches high and it went
under analysis and they found the
remains of beer
and ergot so there's your ergatized beer
this crazy idea from 1978
we now have you know actual scientific
data to corroborate that
which is pretty crazy i'm trying to
think
about what the reason would be i i
understand that the
christian church was being pretty
forthcoming at
trying to convert everybody they were
you know they were they were full-on
they were
it was a big relationship with the
christians um but i'm trying to work out
what the the fear that they would have
had as opposed to repurposing
the existing ritual and just rebranding
it
why they would get rid of it and i think
i've heard you talk about this before
that
it would taking a psychoactive substance
gives you
direct access to god in one
form or another you no longer actually
need the medium that is the church or
the priest or the
um the religion at white you just
it's you and him speaking directly to
him is that your
sort of conception of it as well i think
that's again i think that's part
of the answer um it it's hard for me to
figure out what was going on in the
fourth century and
i think i'm on record saying something
like i sympathize with the church
fathers and i'm not sure what i mean by
that
but um know but they were
they were in the business of of church
building which at the time is in the
business of nation building
and how do you do that with this secret
illegal cult
where people are meeting in private with
no standards who the hell knows what's
going on
behind closed doors are literally
underground in family catacombs
i mean this is where christianity took
root in private houses
and catacombs for 300 years there was no
brick and mortar churches there were no
physical basilicas until constantine
in the 4th century a.d so once it comes
above ground
literally and once um you know
christians aren't being hunted down by
lions
you know how do you get this faith off
the ground and i think that you need
standards
and you need dogma which is why all
these church councils get together and
they figure out which books go in and
which don't
and yeah there was a hack job going on i
mean there's you know the um
the the gnostic literature disappears um
all these texts from non-hamadi egypt
for example that were dug up in the
middle of the 20th century and these
beautiful
beautiful testimonies that talk about a
different jesus like in the gospel of
thomas
or the gospel of mary magdalene which is
now i think over 125 years old
you know there were other versions of
the faith out there and slowly but truly
they start to disappear
in the fourth and fifth centuries now
again part of that
is the church trying to do what it does
which is you know build a bureaucracy
create something coherent
um which they've never been able to do
successfully
right this is why we have the schism
between the catholic and orthodox and
then we have the protestants now we have
the evangelicals and everything else i
mean
it's hard to hold this thing together
what i sense in the early years was
was an attempt to cohere
a religion that was very much
in danger of disappearing and along with
that goes all these secrets and all
these mysteries
talk us through your experience
researching in the vatican obviously
this sounds
pretty heretical why why did they even
let you
near rome i don't know
that's a good question
i'm still trying to figure that out so
what do you do do you email the pope do
you send him a dm on twitter what
happens
yeah i was like um you know frank it's
brian um
you got some cool stuff i'd love to see
it
there it's it's it's not that i mean it
is it's very difficult
to to get your way into the vatican
secret archives
and and the catacombs um you know
i was very honest with with folks you
know i talked to the archivist
at the secret archives and the archive
of the congregation for the doctrine of
the faith which holds these inquisition
records and i went underground with this
vatican archaeologist to look at the
frescoes and these catacombs
and i said you know i would tell people
here's my crazy idea about this
psychedelic eucharist
and um i think it's just as crazy as you
do uh
because i don't know i haven't seen the
hard scientific data for it i'm out
there looking for it all over the
mediterranean
um i'd like to know if there's any
evidence here um you know so part of it
is just asking them if we could test
different vessels and different chalices
which they're sitting on in the hundreds
of thousands
you know in their own handwriting from
the 16th century
or the 15th century is there is there a
mention of these magical potions
uh and the short answer is there is
they're you know they're they were they
were hunting and targeting witches
um at least partly because of their
knowledge of these traditional
healing mechanisms um and sometimes
visionary medicines
uh so it's it's all there preserved um
in the literature
what does it feel like being underneath
the
s the absolute epicenter for the
christian faith rooting through i mean
you're in the
necropolis which is this
bit below the system not below the
sistine chapel below
um the vatican right and there's the
same saint peters
is it bullets and peter's basilica just
multiple layers below that what's it
feel like he must have been it must it's
proper dan brown [ __ ]
it was uh that that's what i said uh to
the priest who was with me this is this
is dan brown [ __ ] and i felt like i'd
never get out like there was a you know
uh
uh there would be the clank of a gate
and that'd be the the last time
i breathe fresh air uh everyone they're
all cool man
they're every everyone's very cool in
the vatican i might be one of the few
people to say that
but everyone uh they're all super cool
to me
um in the officioskavi the excavation
office there um i was looking at you
know what could be one of the first
mosaics one of the first
representations of christian art
directly under saint peter's basilica
in one of these tombs the tombs of the
ulihi and there you see
uh these vines just curling all around
this figure seated on a horse
and i'm not the first person art
historians
have said there's a real mix up here of
jesus and dionysus all these dionesian
vines
you know uh roiling their way around
this mosaic
it's hard to know what to make of that
and it's hard to know what was going on
down there
um because from the records we have
there was some pagan
[ __ ] going on underneath the vatican in
the early days this is where they went
like other catacombs to commune with the
dead
they went there to meet saint peter
before there was a saint peter's
basilica
they went there to camp out amongst
these graves
and host these parties which the
professor emeritus of history at yale
university
calls chill-outs they went to have chill
outs with
the dead uh to drink their wine and have
a feast
every day in some cases so i mean you
know rome was a fun place to be
how does the mysteries at ellucius
relate to the
holy sacrament
i mean well there's a big question and
the how i try to answer that in the book
is by using the mysteries of dionysus
as the translator so you have all these
mysteries at a losses right
and it's these pilgrims making this
march drinking this potion having this
vision
it's all administered by the state so
even though it's technically open to
lots of different people
as we mentioned um it's a very formal
event
at some point you have the mysteries of
dionysus and it takes the
concept of a magical potion takes it out
of the sanctuary
away from the temple so where are the
mysteries of dionysus being celebrated
outdoors open-air churches in the
forests and mountains it's people
getting smashed
in these drunken orgies in honor of the
god of wine right
and then here comes jesus not too long
after that in fact
at the same time i mean in galilee
ancient israel uh ancient palestine you
will find
images of dionysus um all around galilee
i mean so
you know his cult was there at the same
time that the cult of jesus
was just gathering steam um and what is
jesus doing with this magic potion he's
saying
not only can you take it out of the
temple not only can you take it to the
open air
church but take this magic potion that
makes you immortal
nothing less than that and take it into
your dining room so i think by
domesticating these mysteries
i think that for some early christians i
think that's how they would have read
the early accounts of jesus here's this
guy taking an immortality potion that's
his blood
the same way that the dionysus was
described by the way
the blood of dionysus and he's taking it
inside the dining room and saying you
can celebrate this at home
it's okay to do this at home because at
the time that was a sacrilege
in a losus you were not allowed to
celebrate that at home
um we have accounts of people trying to
do that and it was this massive scandal
in athens and so here comes jesus with a
new model to preserve
in some cases these mysteries well you
see the
imagery of the last supper and you've
got
everyone looks fairly cozy you know they
look pretty
they look pretty merry at that situation
i'm aware it's not a photograph
no but we i mean we have the accounts um
aside from the aside from leonardo's
imaginings of it
uh it's for you know the eucharist the
last supper is recorded matthew mark and
luke and john it's really it's weird and
john it's different
um it's jesus giving a sermon outside
but he's talking about the same thing
he's talking about his flesh and blood
and he uses really weird language that
by the way is not jewish
you know so people think about the last
supper and this cozy
affair amongst friends is this you know
this passover meal before his death this
morning of jesus before his death
um i can't think of a single jewish
dinner where where human flesh and blood
is being served and yet here comes jesus
saying
whoever eats my flesh and drinks my
blood
has eternal life not will have not we'll
go to heaven
right here tonight if you drinking meat
you are an
immortal this is the same the same way
these sacraments were described by the
pagans and think about it like munching
on this flesh
it's a really evocative word that jesus
uses in grief there drogon to munch on
my flesh
it's like this really graphic visceral
event that's being described um
so who the hell knows what was going on
did did you totally lose your [ __ ] with
how many questions you have to ask
yourself because every situation that
you come across
everything that you find out is oh
that's interesting and now here's 3
000 questions that are implied by me
knowing this one extra bit
uh you just you described the the
torturous process
of me talking to my editor for a couple
of years
but this chapter is so important man
they're gonna love this chapter
you know it's really essential to the
argument
one thing i was thinking about while
reading the book was
how our existing cultural structures
affect the way that we experience
psychedelics
i know that this may not necessarily be
your precise field of study but it's an
interesting question i want to ask you
anyway
so can you imagine what would be seen by
a human
who grows up in a lab with no cultural
input so what would they
see like how much is the transcendent
effect intrinsic to the drug
and how much is enabled by the existing
narrative frameworks that we have in our
own minds
that's a great question man um it's you
know it does it does tell
it dovetails to my work i mean i do talk
to the clinical psychologists about this
stuff
and the psychopharmacologists what
everyone agrees on is that set and
setting are integral
i mean this is not it's not a wonder
drug um
and more importantly psychedelics just
are not for everybody
which is why they've been successful in
their trials at hopkins and nyu by
screening certain people out
um you know it takes it takes um a
really heroic
emotional psychological preparation to
prepare for this stuff
and you know just think about what the
word psychedelic means in greek it means
to manifest the contents of the psyche
is how i translate it sica delos
and so when that happens i mean before
you even begin thinking about that
why don't you try dusting off those
contents for yourself i mean
you know you dream about them every
night have you addressed
some of those traumas from your
childhood have you addressed some of
those pitfalls in your relationships
um some of that shadow work that plays
out in your everyday life there's lots
of work that you can do before
psychedelics
and which is part of the reason i
haven't done them i mean there's lots of
stuff that you can do
um including mindfulness and meditation
and all the rest of it
um you know so once you get to that
point when when all this stuff is being
laid bare and i don't know what would
happen to someone who was grown in a lab
um uh that'd be an interesting
experiment uh
it'd be hard to get fda approval for
that uh but uh
you know what's what what people are i
think people are playing on memories and
people are playing
you know on the archetypal things that
live inside the subconscious of all
humans
which is really powerful stuff there's
this thing this these images come
out i mean you know a christian will
have an image of a of an
indian deity and you know uh some guy in
the uk will have an image of a mayan god
and it's really hard to explain
why that's the case that's what that's
what fascinated me about it i wonder
obviously as you say slightly unethical
and um perhaps unrealistic
experiment to run but it would be
fascinating to see
because that would be the ultimate um
you'll be able to control exclusively
for cultural inputs for
all of the existing narratives there's
certain things you get
the visual distortion that almost
everybody says in terms of geometric
patterns
for instance so you perhaps always going
to have that
uh no matter what you're looking at no
matter who you are what you've grown up
what your thought
patterns are like inside of your mind
but can you imagine
if people reported these people who were
grown up without these cultural inputs
cultural narratives and frameworks
inside of their mind
and they reported similar manifestations
which would be this is something
universally held within us
all i don't know i just thought that was
i thought that was a really interesting
thought experiment
i like that i mean but you know some of
the researchers do do write about this
bill richardson
uh who's one of the researchers at
hopkins does write about this about
the encounter with the archetypes i mean
there are our people who haven't been
trained in or to the best of their
knowledge haven't been
substantively exposed to some of these
traditions
that do pop up i mean kind of
spontaneously
like you know gods and goddesses from
different faith traditions that just
don't belong in the contents of
someone's psyche on the eastern coast of
the united states
and yet in comes this stuff
did you discuss with anybody about the
potential dosage
or an equivalent dosage that people may
have been consuming
in the ancient that's what's really hard
man uh so even though
even though we found some of the
archaeo-botanical archaeochemical
evidence
to this day to the best of my knowledge
the this cookie on potion
or some of this spiked wine hasn't been
recreated to the standards of antiquity
um so i mean that's something i very
much want to do even with this find in
spain
we still want to re-test uh that chalice
and and really figure out like what was
the formula
here what were the measurements uh
because by all accounts like an uh
ergatized beer
is not the most pleasant trip i mean
it's kind of terrifying i mean ergotism
traditionally leads to all kinds of
really unfun things like gangrene and
convulsions and
and stuff like that but maybe what i've
been thinking recently is that maybe it
was a very low dose and other folks have
mentioned this to me who are more
experienced than me
uh but maybe it was a low dose that
again just kind of um that rejiggered
the brain somehow that just said it i
mean just just to the left
of of normal after all that fasting
maybe some sleep deprivation the long
march from from athens for example
a low dose a lower dose of ergotized
beer could have been the kind of thing
um to have a really powerful vision i
don't know
it's just there's so many questions man
has anything come out
since your book was published has there
been are you
continuing to research are you still is
there a sequel
like what what's your current oh there
is a sequel wow
it's all it's all happening man um as
just one one tiny example
um national geographic and others
reported in november i think it was
about this uh you can google it the
pinwheel cave the pinwheel cave
in california uh from the chumash tribe
i think it's only a few hundred years
old so it's it's not going into deep
antiquity
but about 400 or so years ago
they found this cave with a da tourer
flower
painted on the ceiling of this cave and
inside crevices
in the rock they actually found the
organic remains of dotura quits
which is a very hallucinogenic uh plants
flower
um it has contains all these propane
alkaloids
the same kind of alkaloids that may have
been present in
these wine potions i mentioned that
diascoretes was writing about in the
first century a.d
uh so a very interesting find and it was
called the very first archaeochemical
evidence
uh for the coexistence of rock art and
psychedelic drugs and i mean that
happens in 2020 for no reason whatsoever
um at the time that all this you know
we're talking about all this stuff so
you know
every time i open the the computer
there's another story out there
what's next for you uh so
we're still doing uh this documentary
series and um
pushing forward on that i am writing
a second book that is
very much related to but distinct from
the first one
without giving too much away um lots
more clues
um lots of more ancient signals and
you know the big question what does this
mean for the future
of medicine religion society all those
kind of questions in the midst of a
global pandemic
and economic turmoil and civil unrest
and political discontent i mean i think
it's a very interesting moment
that we're living in and people are
looking for meaning and isn't it
interesting to think about this
continuity
right not just from the greeks and the
christians but maybe to us and maybe
we're living at this moment where some
of this technology
is is being resurrected it's uh it's a
big question
well think about what people have turned
to in this time of need
copies of marcus aurelius's meditations
and paperback were sold out
at the beginning of 2020. you think well
why would someone go
1800 years back to a philosophy
that was it aristotle or plato that
thought the brain
only existed to get rid of heat out of
the body
and you're like you know on some stuff
they were so right and on other stuff
so far off in germ theory hadn't gone
through
when as a marcus aurelius is dying
from the plague as he's caught in the at
the ant-9 plague
there he's struggling to breathe because
of the amount of
incense that's burning in the room
because they thought that incense would
get rid
of the plague it would help to get rid
of the air particles in the air and all
that they were doing was
forcing marcus aurelius to like smell
like someone's awful auntie's house
like the the spiritual the spiritual
auntie who's always burning incense it's
just like forcing him to do that
so on one side you have these people who
are obviously
incredibly detached from what we
understand now
and yet the more universal elements the
things that they were able to observe
more accurately
human nature meaning flourishing what
does it mean to be virtuous to have
temperance
those things are what people in 2021
are going back to they're relying more
on the writings of marcus aurelius than
they are on anybody for the last 1800
years
and this crescent
this story arc that we're coming back to
psychedelics
precisely the same if what you say
is true if what you've discovered is
correct and it's taken us
around about 2 000 years to
start using therapeutically something
which could have aided the last
two millennia of human civilization
then we have a lot of catching up to do
and it is just fascinating the way that
these
things are coming in full circle
i agree that's beautifully put man i i
couldn't say it better than that you
just you just wrote the back cover
that's perfect
fine that's that's i'll give you the
rights we can we can discuss deals off
air
man i've today brian it's
so fascinating your dedication to this
you've been told it a million times but
your dedication to this project is
ridiculous psychopathic um and in
in the good way in the in the great way
not in the brian rose from london
railway
um where can people go they want to keep
up to date
with what it is that you're doing where
should they head
i'm not going to spell my romanian name
so i'll say um the
immortalitykey.com if you go to
themmortalitykey.com
uh you'll see my homepage there and it
links to all my social media
so i try and keep it updated and i'm
usually terrible about it but i'm better
on twitter
and instagram so you can see some
updates there everything will be linked
in the show notes below including a link
to the immortality key wherever you can
get a hold of it
man i'm going to have to get you back
home we're going to have to talk about
the new book and the
when tom hanks decides to accept the
role and whatever new discoveries we've
got so
round two will happen soon i'm i'm there
[Music]
brother
you